we're gonna jump into the relationship
advice this first one is from Andrew
from birthday man sorry Theo
that's okay I'm sorry - it's okay but
first from Western Australia this is
Andrew yang buzz buzz Chang closed
obviously Thea I've got to apologize men
is the story I live in Perth Western
Australia waa
I actually slept with a girl a little
while ago two weeks ago I woke up in the
morning doing some icebreaker stuff you
know trying to make that connection I
showed us some of your stand-up that LSD
bit where you you're doing the jingle
bells stuff opening for Coco Diaz
[ __ ] hilarious man
much appreciated a bright idea that you
would down the road from me watching my
local team play Ozzy rules football so
oh my fault not yours
Brizzy here's the question Brendon both
of you I got a four year old son I have
an ex-girlfriend who ran off for the
best friend of mine I'm trying to be
that good dad but I keep saying the dude
the best friend I keep saying on the
street and I want to put hands on him
what do I do
be a good dad ignore it forgive give me
some advice and gang buzz buzz buzz
thanks for the question yeah thanks for
the question shout out Brisbane Lions I
think this is one's for you Brendan
really yeah you just have a child and
yes you know and you fought people more
than I have dude I've fought more
animals than you but you fought more
people than I am yeah if it came to a
kangaroo I throw it your way or women I
thought your way but fight American
animals mostly yeah but will you answer
this guy's question please um so here's
a four-year-old listen he can't be
fighting people in the street as a dad
man also it's her loss you sound like an
awesome dude so [ __ ] them let her go
ruin that other dude's life but don't
get in a fight man and listen you're
gonna fight on house in Australia pretty
loosey-goosey out there but in America
you know fight you're going to prison so
you don't lose time with your son don't
get in a fight man also [ __ ] them it
shows it shows that it's getting to you
if you fight the dude yeah I would just
you know what you need to do just go
find the most died me dime in Australia
and just start [ __ ] posting videos of
you - slapping kangaroos yeah I think
that some of that's not good so you
Justin's but I think that um you know I
think that can't be what about the kid
what do you mean what about the kid
here's what I say don't get into a fight
get into a murder that's what I say no
especially in Australia dude that
country is built on murderers no it's
not they have way less murder than us
but they're a gun cuz they're tired
they're all murderers they grew up
murdering each other their dired
don't you know the history of Australia
yeah I do your mom probably skip that
chapter thanks dude I bet you're the
historama estrellas explain it then if
it has Moby Dick in it you're [ __ ]
high you're done so you think he should
beat up this dude I'm saying you should
beat this dude up but not in city limits
cat daddy that's what I'm saying take
this boy out and just take my house shed
Oh hide his body inside of a cactus you
feel me yeah sometimes man sometimes you
gotta let the dog loose but with that
said man I think you know yeah you can
also just kind of let them go on about
their business you know maybe take a
little time outside of town though but
you can be gonna be stalking the dude or
doing our throwing rocks across the
street or anything like that you know if
you're gonna do something do something
heavy bro go to jail be an inmate don't
be just a guy who just you know goes to
court for a fight
yeah you need to get respect and if
you're gonna do it you and your boys and
stomp them out from the whole population
no film it live I'll get you y'all
worldstar you don't get your boys in
there dude I think you go maybe put some
shields or something on or some body
artillery or something and get out there
man
but I hope they don't fight him us
joking it good luck my man I would say
be patient I would say rethink about it
in a week everything about fighting
right now wait a week and then think
about I'd say revenge is best served
cold so I get some time peace in
Australia which they're everywhere and
just flex on them on the gram I think if
revenge is best served cold and I'd fill
your mouth with ice cubes and beat the
[ __ ] out of that guy
sorry I'm still kind of in a bad mood
from the cigarette no you're good back
up my broccolini get your life together
I'm not touching